[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle définition donc l'otan une rumeur
qu'elle connotation à souk ahras point
sincère je ne sais pas pour ce que
laissait le thème rebelles elle est
déroulé plus utilisé mais les deux plus
galvaudé et banalisé par même temps
venant pour d'être africain avec son
corollaire du coup d'état de
contestation des élections onpe 1-0
propre rôle
pourquoi certaines qui la liste le
moribond pour y arriver
chaque année moins dix habitants à ce
qui me concerne je n'utilise que ce que
laissaient faire du mieux c'est a dit
écrit venir vers nous et parler c'est
bien sa monnaie faible
un verbe vibre d'oppression de sangsues
de manipulation est exempt du coeur
c'est bien simple table pour être belle
elle s'opposait à toute forme
d'injustice et d'un verdissement ses
fins elle révèle que moi c'est une
question de bon sens voire le suivi et
quand on regarde aujourd'hui toute
l'injustice qui est faite aux
populations
chaque jour je suis choqué franchement
de voir autour des personnes acceptées
les justifie
et franchement je peux pas attraper la
jc dans ma tête c'est pas possible
mais puisqu'on prend pour comprendre
quand je venais lebel je n'ai pas des
communes
comment espionner le bel il fallait tout
en arrière je suis un 30 mai 1986 à
partir d'une main c'est une bataille
vous conviendrez avec moi que ce n'est
pas toute façon une femme se d'éduquer
son enfant dans une société où le
patriarcat a encore de beaux jours
devant lui une société dans laquelle une
femme de se voir mais est
automatiquement considéré comme une
pestiférée une femme au jardin kotov une
femme mince léger c'est la set société
phallocratique à qui j'ai grandi de sa
grossesse à ma naissance
ma mère a dit supporter des railleries
les injures de toute une communauté du
berceau à des six ans ce fut le retour
d'en faire les frais exor de mots
d'amour est-ce qu'on vous abonner sait
combien d ilife 9 ans qui vit seul à
résoudre à nous je me paraissent d'avant
matin lorsqu'un inconnu de tous jouent
avec leur embarras enfin le niveau
chances de réussite à l'âge
quelque 9,6 et de ses champs c'est
pareil honneur vendu de tous les temps
c'est vraiment serré tâche par à 6 ans
dans la seconde il était débordant
d'énergie et v bouillargues il est il
voulait montrer à tout le monde qu'il se
fait les acrobaties soupe et tout et
tout faire du talent bruno bauer la nar
le sida les pouces et c'est au tour dans
une case en mouillant du dîner boy le
militant la médaille peu d'élus
j'avais une brute repreneur degré six
mois de combats
deux organisations est elle de
convalescence c'est une grosse une aide
et 35e je met le pied à l'école pour la
première fois à l'âge but 10
à l'inversé les ménages étaient des
anciens pour agir plus sur d'aujourd'hui
il se la pète en sixième
cette séquence de rita arabe et non je
pensais et voulait mais petr et pourtant
lui caresser les réformes aussi
défigurée par l'accident par le visage
la tête du parti co manager depuis la
naissance on n'a pas joué avec un enfant
bâtard donc quand la vie à l'école je
suis accueillie avec des records le
monstre leadeuse avec dell se donner
dans la presse unis balabala la famille
de bruit double face toutes les pâtes
des pseudonymes que le mérite de montrer
le bout du nez à l'épaule de même de
vivre mais elle joue ma grand mère me
dit madame tenait le volant bien je vois
pas l'écologie à mclaren
vous parlez moi mais ça et puis tout ça
c'est pas de la semaine à cause de moi
de voir le pouvoir ne s'arrête pas d un
soutien ma grammaire du regard et les
non marcheurs avaient des bonnes tables
comme i want that we travel et en a
remporté deux étapes d'ardus l'amdi
porte est par ailleurs me dit tu parles
de nos droits sur you wanna fille
et quand la nuit thaddée ce ne sera pas
facile
le château de grandes choses le tir à
l'épaule il soit le premier à te moquer
du doigt même ses responsables du douar
nous prendra la suite
mais si celle ci défend toile donner des
avis et je viens ma grammaire il
mènerait à un élément c'est la vie est à
6 fois où ça va à l'école on se ment
d'ivoire depuis board y faire je suis
parent pauvre monsieur le vieil c'est la
grande leçon alpha de mon obligation
mais si elles viendront ils bridge
houphouet je pense alors à pointer la
limite il indique ne pas faire je le
trouvais les autres médaillés ali al
aswad sur le poster vos goûts
au fond je parlais mais qu'ils ne
veulent bien parce qu'ils parlent tous
la souffre douleur du coq
j'étais le superbe le passé comment
j'arrive
les eaux sont soumis à las vegas et au
milieu de ces têtes h 30 à vis de le
mans serait pas là a libéré l'as tu
comprendras même la réponse est oui je
suis mais franchement j'ai pas compris
c'est celui là il aurait dû sort le
commence où les attendait le coeur de
vos bourreaux la ville de l'agaci et
encore une fois il continue de ne pas
des plus belles la mandoline à tous vous
rappeler que la grenade ça continue
faute des femmes dans les fêtes de
bahreïn depuis dix ans nous fera
aujourd'hui la tour surtout le betar et
man tôt
je regarde jeunes au regard du mois
c'est pas fort comme papa l'école
jeunesse du parti chez seat management
c'est celle ci pourra science force je
lui saute à la gorge dès les faits
connus servent la voix a capella de ces
gens frappent le maître lemaire et un
renfort à la seule fois il me souvient
d'un vol
je me suis posé la question
quitte à envoyer une pièce à l'écart de
choses j'avais deux cas je le lâche
dessus des normales
l ol désole jean vaut la papeterie
poussoir jeu ma revanche un empereur est
un vrai lieu d harvey pourquoi vous
sépare donc je m'avance dans le village
hiver soit nous sommes fatigués tom à la
fondation
je lui met sa brave gars est décrit
points le mythe et soigneux des mois amy
millan et orbi j'étais heureux parce que
la première fois de ma vie je venais de
tenir tête à 7009 six coloris noir et
physiquement
là je repars j'allais faire pour le
plaisir
tellement bien sûr qu'elle travers pour
l'aixois nous c'est bon pour me lâcher
j'étais le portail qui faisaient de la
soigner à partir souverain j'ai senti un
besoin
le bg venir en aide pour ce temps le
besoin de défense que tu fais comme moi
auparavant
et quand on est les gars de plus près
c'est pour ça qu'elle ne la revoit
décembre
en grandissant celui qui l'avait que ce
point comme moyen d'expression à
protester contre 8 1 le bayer est il
bien que plus l'egypte les enfants ma
plume le verbe des orchestrations pour
lutter qu'elle suit les travers de la
société société dans laquelle
l'invitèrent l'illégalité
l'inégalité l'inéquité sur les maîtres
mots sous c'était dans laquelle les plus
faibles sont constamment écrasés par les
plus forts le quinté n'était pas un de
lustration parfaite qui pourrait
l'arrêter réussi une baraque logique du
fait d'un accident de la circulation à
qui on refuse l'accès à l'époque au
motif fallacieux qu'un silence de
roulement et glossy complet dit ça cela
va tuer une source de sécurité aps la
banque de vous y verrez les suspicions
et ses droits les plus élémentaires être
par hui foulé au pied du volcan
d'injustice j'ai été choquée d'entendre
des gentils on a tous les avantages
donc je les apprends comment son père
sept soldats
comment est ce que on peut s'accorder
s'assumer femme âgée tard et se
familiariser avec l'injustice des
certitudes que je comprends cette
citation de mathieu de lutins qui
diffusait ce qui m'effraie ce n'est pas
l'oppression des méchants c'est les
différences des bois - dans la poubelle
et je n'ai pas arrêté sur des dessous
des temps modernes ou urbain de boire en
comment elle voudrait pas mal
mais jamais je dis bien jamais je n'ai
rester indifférent aucune douleur et les
souffrances d'un dernier jeu le calculer
le coût par l'injustice où qu'ils soient
et personne je dis bien personne même si
vous visez on est palpable
le dixième à l'entreprise a pas sa part
la présence physique de briguer le bon
nationale le bon bout
il se dégage de paris est sous le charme
de la belle d'un sujet d'insoumis de
révolte et citait le tas vous n'êtes pas
au bout de vos peines parce que j'ai
laissé révèle juste en avant comme
facebook qu'ils valent assurément mieux
je suis capable de sentir plus de
profondeur au coeur n'est pas quelle
injustice qu'il a commise à l'endroit
des dépôts qui est notre cas nul c'est
ça la qualité d'un grand que vous lui
donnez le thème ce soir c'est notre
rédaction les autres chacun de weezy un
des jeux ou vos trois autres amis vous
n'importe quelle personne en panne vous
êtes autres êtres porte parole des sans
voix car c'est seulement comme ça qu on
pourra limiter les justices ambiante
dans lequel nous payons aujourd'hui et
dont les autres
bien dans la migraine
dites à votre arrivée au club
un temps la zone
delhaize sachez le c'est des soins mais
elle a surtout permet d'être utile à la
société
aider les autres c'est s'ouvrir
opportunités aider les autres ça bouge
beaucoup de potes mais c'est vous dire
aussi que leur mérite est d'être heureux
chacun de nous ici a subi une injustice
dans sa vie chacun de vous sait les face
à un cas d'injustice offert ce congrès
et puis à mon aîné de vous informer des
changements avec cette justice là il est
invaincu face nombre d'animaux et chacun
de nous est sur le post un roulant de ce
monde
ma réponse à voir je vais trouver c'est
d'écrire ou rival honni par les était
faible
ceux qui ne suivent pas et puis ceux qui
ne peuvent pas parler ce qui n'est pas
si différent
et vous quelle arrogance il vous le m
ali